[Musik]
was sucht kam für die aktion
das bin ich vor zwei wochen
hat das stück einfach nicht los und
drückt sich dann das
gedanke wenn ich das einfach
zerbrechen
das ist eine reportage über junge frauen
mit essstörungen sie kämpfen gegen kilos
und kalorien und das was sie am meisten
ablehnen ist die eigener körper
[Musik]
in diesem haus leben ausschließlich
frauen mit suchterkrankungen und
essstörungen behandelt die klinik wies
hölz lee im bernischen herzogenbuchsee
heute zieht eine neue 1 nicole wagner
leidet an anorexie also an
appetitlosigkeit und magersucht sie
kommt wie übrigens alle frauen
freiwillig hierher die 26-jährige hat
bereits mehrere therapien hinter sich
keiner war erfolgreich
nun setzt sie all ihre hoffnungen in die
fachklinik
nebst ihrer essstörung leidet die
26-jährige an depressionen ihr
leidensweg begann im alter von acht
jahren als sie mit der familie in ein
anderes dorf zu
dorf
schläge und zu ja
also ich gleich 660 momentan klappt es
ungefähr zwischen petrys gehalten sechs
gehalt
kritik an menschen ja selber hand
zuzuführen nur ein gedanke
nahe
verwandte oder war passiert wenn es
nicht gelingt ist noch abhängig von
menschen oder man weiß nie was passiert
noch ein tod kranich und
einzig max ist dass wir
schneller steht der kranke musste sie
die lehre als kaufmännische angestellte
abbrechen nicole wagner ist arbeitslos
und bezieht eine iv-rente
[Musik]
gesprächsterminen mit psychologin marcel
jäger lehner und martina scheibel der
ärztlichen leiterin der klinik
wir haben gemerkt dass ihnen die
erkrankung auch etwas gibt sind nimmt
ihnen hält nur ein normales leben sie
gibt danach was setzte dahintergekommen
gar nicht
warum sollte die danach aber
dann nicht mal eben
so kommt das gespenst ich will
eigentlich gesund sein doch immer noch
wie erwartet die glied zurück pro woche
es wird eco ich trainiere das buch das
sie so am zur asse wie das ich am
liebsten alles park und abbricht und das
ist dann schon x-mal woche
ich sage einerseits wäre es wieder
bestätigung scheiße deutsch zu sein und
andere sieht werder blieb
das nicht aber direkt tot
das habe ich noch versucht beim
abklärung gespräch auch klar zu machen
das ist ein sehr steiniger weg ist aus
dem verhaltens statistischen jahre lang
leben auch immer wieder klinik bedeutet
werde doch für die zurückkomme in das
alte gewicht nicht weiter zu können den
sogleich breche dann braucht ziemlich
das braucht ziemlich strenge regeln und
ich habe sie nachher gesagt die amelia
wir gegen die regeln verstößt riskiert
den ausschluss aus der klinik
[Musik]
daniel schläfli ist seit 34 jahren
patienten in wisla
warum würde sie dann jetzt in spiegel
machen auch viel zu lachen so einfach
ist es gut
ich es gut dass
hier
längst normal und
das
will was
sind sie denn
es ist nicht ungefährlich aber das ist
ja
das ist das was
das
kochen ist teil der therapie für die 28
jährige daniel schlee fliegt ist die
beschäftigung mit essen mit einem
starken inneren konflikt verbunden denn
die studierte primar 1 ausgerechnet auch
noch angehende ernährungsberaterin die
fachhochschule hat sie erfolgreich
abgeschlossen noch fehlt allerdings das
dazugehörige praktikum
[Musik]
oder
irgendwie
der konflikt wo man hat dass sie
eigentlich auslöste und blicke ihres
verhaltens
türen ja
ich denke die patientinnen und patienten
das waren immer so gut machen so richtig
danken
dieser knopf und inhalt fluch und jetzt
muss sie bei kirchen judith milliman
wieder lernen was ihr körper wirklich
braucht kalorien
wichtig dass die regelmäßig mahlzeiten
fünf bis sechs mal zittern hessens man
das noch der blutzucker nicht so aber
sinkt und zweitens das einfach arrigo
mäßigem an sicherheit gewinnen die
rettungsgasse sortiment vor dem
ersehnten
zusammenstöße
zwischen für die natur
wird zweck hilft die ausläufer von miss
li na und die zuhörer ja heute gerade
mal machen damit man das nennen
ausgesehen
ist das jetzt möglich wo sie eigentlich
müsste dort aus wieder wichtig
dass weder richtig lehrer und also es
war jetzt nicht so dass sie natürlich
wahnsinnig
[Musik]
auch sarah kleiner ist patientin in der
klinik in der fast 40 frauen behandelt
werden essen war für die 29 jährige
jahrelang eine qual deshalb hungerte
sich die gelernte pflegeassistentin fast
zu tode und
häftling
druck
so
groß
schlank
macht
[Musik]
in der entspannungstherapie lernen die
patienten in ihren körper besser
wahrzunehmen
fast alle sind jung das ist kein zufall
jede zehnte frau unter 35 jahren ist in
der schweiz von einer essstörung
betroffen
nicole wagner fühlt sich in der klinik
nicht wohl
oft zieht sie sich zurück
bei sozialarbeiterin supreme chakraborty
beklagt nicole ihre situation
[Musik]
berlins bilder mit dem symrise 3 die
sozialarbeiterin sucht zusammen mit
nicole nach möglichkeiten ihr kontakt
problem zu lösen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unten im keller der klinik übt daniel
für einen konzertauftritt
das
konzertorchester
und das eigentlich dachte ich wenn sie
am steuer therapiert unterstützt das ja
zum knobeln ach ja
rund um die klinik hat es viele
spazierwege sie werden von den
patientinnen rege benützt
frauen mit essstörungen haben einen
ausgeprägten bewegungsdrang
[Musik]
jeden montag nachdem wochenendurlaub
müssen die patientinnen auf die waage
stehen
[Musik]
schwerer werden ist für die
untergewichtigen frauen pflicht wer es
nicht schafft muss am darauf folgenden
wochenende in der klinik bleiben
zur knop und wenn sie
abgesagt und darum ich das so abgemacht
dass sie
umgehend will sarah das resultat
erfahren
das bedeutet viel für sie ja
weißt du alles und eine vierte sachen
verdient belohnt das mehrheit
[Musik]
weniger anlass zur freude hat daniel
schläfli sie ist kein gramm schwerer
geworden
das heißt dass richter
das letztendlich blieben einfach
griechisch oder wenn man abgesehen hat
ersetzt konsequenzen
könnte
die erste konsequenz ist dass in den
letzten
zwei wochen und ich hoffe dass ich auch
noch mitspielen wo wir schon vorher
machen
[Musik]
daniels rückfall ist thema beim gespräch
mit psychologin nicole jäger sie will im
detail erfahren was die patientin
gegessen hat
also ich werde gar timmermann was wie
solche schnell zum beispiel über die ski
noch zunehmen denn im nachstochern aviv
und combat zone
liegen die sonne
massiven druck gespürt dass sowie eines
ich habe es gar nichts vorstellen dass
es nur so viel braucht mehr kredit werde
seine gedanken dass auch die restriktive
gedankengang euch was ist mit einem 8
wirklich alles
weil so viele portionen nach dem
üblichen
ja eigentlich sogar das ist gewiss wenig
statisch ist das buch können also doch
recht
die zimmermänner bisher das sagen
hat
[Musik]
krisen gehören hier zum alltag die
patientin in der roten jacke hat
suizidgedanken und muss in eine
psychiatrische klinik verlegt werden die
frau leidet nicht an magersucht sondern
ein bin also ein heißhunger anfällen die
folge davon ist meist übergewicht
essstörungen kommen vor allem bei frauen
vor auslöser sind oft sexuelle
übergriffe psychischen störungen und ein
gestörtes verhältnis zum eigenen körper
[Musik]
die 19 jährige noemi schmid ist wegen
bulimie
ess-brech-sucht bereits zum zweiten mal
im wie salz lee bei ihrem letzten
aufenthalt plagten sie schwere
depressionen
gemacht
also
medikamente
oder
noemi überlebten nur weil sie sich im
letzten augenblick noch beim
pflegepersonal gemeldet hatte
am wochenende zu hause in saras wohnung
mit den basel
die 29 jährige hat ihre eltern
eingeladen
[Musik]
bobby und christine kleiner sind stets
zur stelle wenn ihre tochter sie braucht
und das kommt oft vor den sarah hat ein
problem sie kann nicht alleine sein
mit luther machen und uns
[Musik]
waren jedermannrennen möchte wie sie den
sie mir gegangen wäre
sagt sie für uns im schlaf ins freie
gerade erst wieder auf der
[Musik]
sie das
gehörte sich jetzt ich bin ein bolt mit
ihrer freundin anna eder freut und die
oft dass das jetzt so blieb das doch
nicht einmal ein rückfall geht
in der fachklinik für frauen in
herzogenbuchsee hat nicole wagner besuch
erhalten ein glücklicher moment für die
patientin die sich oft genug als
außenseiterin empfindet nicole ist
dankbar dass sie wenigstens eine
freundin hat désirée
bonafini lang gemeldet dass trotzdem hat
das mail schreiben dass er mit
praktika sowie bis weil ich bin nicht
dass sie die
wechselgesänge laura so also bitte hat
die klage zu hause die nerven hoch der
wahrheitsgehalt
[Musik]
in der kunsttherapie beschäftigt sich
daniel schläfli mit dem thema
weiblichkeit sieg leistet sich eine
flamencotänzerin mit runden formen haben
sie die bewusster gemacht
na
logisch dass
berlin nicht wofür den kräften haben
wenn ich spüre sie zur kamera
aber
sind wir in
diesem umfang noch immer maßgeblich
vormachen
auch sarah kleiner setzt sich in der
kunsttherapie mit sich selber
auseinander
anschließend bespricht kunsttherapeutin
susanne goder mit der patientin das bild
sarah zieht eine wichtige erkenntnis aus
ihrer arbeit
[Musik]
und so braucht es noch manche
gruppentherapie und manches gespräch bis
die patientinnen die klinik verlassen
bis zu einem halben jahr oder sogar noch
länger dauert die behandlung wie sally
nur jede dritte frau ist danach wirklich
geheilt
einige wochen später hat daniel schnell
wie ihr erstes grosses ziel auf dem weg
zurück in den alltag erreicht
[Musik]
weil sie wieder etwas zugenommen hat
darf sie am konzertauftritt des new york
es dass bern teilnehmen
noch hat sie ihre essstörung nicht
überwunden denn das ist kein leichtes
spiel
[Musik]
[Applaus]